The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, good afternoon.
So in the last couple of weeks,
we've gone through some
of the major human capacities
that you have and I have and
most people have most
of them, right?
Which are the ability to see the
world around us, to attend
to what's important, to learn
lessons from life, to remember
things, why we sometimes
forget things.
And today, we're going to talk
about another huge dimension
of human experience, of the
human mind, of the human
brain, language.
The ability to talk
to one another.
I can talk, you can listen,
and vice versa.
To read, to communicate,
in the ways that are so
remarkable.
Our life is flooded with
language, right?
That we hear, that we
read, and so on.
So when psychologists try to
divide up language and the
study of both components, they
talk about comprehension,
understanding what somebody
says to you when you're an
infant, or now, as an adult, or
reading text, or producing
speech, which you can do with
your mouth by speaking, or you
learn to write.
So you can both comprehend and
produce language, both
visually and orally.
And the thing that has greatly
enamored linguists to figure
out is how language that we
speak is endlessly generative.
I'm not sure you can actually
calculate out how many
sentences we could possibly
produce, but just for fun,
people have done stuff.
And they said it would take 100
trillion years to memorize
all the sentences
we can produce.
I'm not sure that's
exactly the right
number, but it's a lot.
Because we can say a lot of
different sentences and
understand what a person
is saying.
It's an incredibly generative
system for communication, one
person to another.
So when people in psychology
think about different aspects
of language, levels of language,
they often divide it
into something like this.
Phonology is the sounds of
language that we hear, that we
acquire as infants, that we use
to speak to one another.
Syntax, grammar.
And by this, this isn't school
grammar, not get
the sentence right.
It's just the understanding of
the organization of words, and
how that changes the meaning
of the sentence.
Syntax.
Semantics, what do
the words mean?
What do the groups
of words mean?
Pragmatics.
And we'll talk about each
of these a little bit.
Sometimes a person
is sarcastic.
So they go, that was an awesome
lecture yesterday in
psychology.
Somebody could say that, in
a hundred trillion years.
And you go, yeah, yeah.
Right?
So that's the pragmatics
versus semantics.
Then, of course, it's
not just sentences.
We have whole discussions.
And another aspect of language
we'll just touch on a little
bit today is emotional
comprehension and production.
The tone somebody speaks in, the
tone you produce, are also
informative.
So there's many aspects
of language.
We'll start with the most
basic, or phonology.
So phonemes are the words that
people use to describe the
building blocks of
speech sounds.
So boy versus toy are different
by one phoneme.
Phonemes are the building
blocks of
the sounds of language.
Humans use about 100 phonemes
across languages, but any
given language only
uses a subset.
And this has really interesting
consequences.
Of course, a language could only
exist in the world if you
could understand
those phonemes.
Phonemes that are
ununderstandable aren't going
to be a part of anybody's
language.
But different languages, for
historical reasons, have ended
up using different subsets
of phonemes.
And we'll come back to that.
When we're babies, for about
the first six months of our
lives, we're universal
learners.
We know all the phonemes and
respond to all of them.
As we become native language
speakers and listeners, we
become only good at the ones
that are used in our language,
and our ability to even
recognize the ones that are
not in our language
disappears.
You can get it back some, but
the older that you are, you
never get it back fully.
So we're universal learners at
birth, but we become enslaved
to the language that we are
native speakers of and listen
to within months of birth.
English has about 45.
So it's more than the number
of letters we have.
Some people get confused
a little bit
that letters are phonemes.
They're not.
So hot and cold, the oh sound
in hot and the oh sound in
cold are different sounds,
same letters.
So there's many more phonemes.
Even in English, when they say
there's about 45, depending on
dialects, you could have a
couple more, a couple less.
So again, we're born
to use all of them.
Then we use them or lose them.
It's something, we don't
entirely lose it, but we're
never as good if we try to learn
a distinction once we
become older than that.
Humans understand speech
at an incredible rate.
The typical fast talking is
about 180 words a minute, 14
phonemes a second in a
continuous speech stream.
But people can go
up to 250 words.
We're incredibly fast language
processors, incredibly fast
language processors.
So how do we roughly
conceptualize, in the most
simple way, what we have to do
to get to a word that we hear,
to get to its meaning.
Well, acoustic information
comes through the ear.
Those are wave forms, physical
things, arriving at our ears.
We in some way figure out how
those correspond to phonemes,
and then map that in some
way to words that have
meanings in the world.
And the reason why machines
understanding what you say is
shockingly hard to do
a good job on is for
the following reason.
There's a huge difference
between a word by the time
your mind understands what it
is and the nature of the
signal that arrived
at your year.
So we talked a lot about
that in terms of
the retina in vision.
Right?
You have this very impoverished
stuff that
arrives in your retina, and then
the whole rest of your
brain, millions and millions
of neurons and synapses,
reconstruct what's out there
from a very impoverished
retinal input.
And the same thing happens
in audition.
What gets to your ear is
incredibly impoverished, and
the rest of your brain has to
brilliantly reconstruct what
it heard and assign
its meaning.
And so part of the challenge of
your mind and brain to do
that is this.
This is a representation of
something like the physical
signal that arrives
at your ear.
And you could say, well,
here's one word.
Here's another word.
What's the problem?
But this is all the signal that
arrives at your ear for
the word captain.
So here's the C, all this stuff
for the A, a period of
long silence that sets
up the P. Turns out--
I'll convince you of
this in a moment--
that our speech is full within
words of silent breaks that
are incredibly informative and
alter our perception of what's
physically going on.
Then the little T. This
long stuff for the AI.
This long stuff for the N.
So the physical signal to your
ear barely resembles what
seems like a single
unit, captain.
And where's that pause?
A person doesn't say, "cap," or
doesn't say "ca," one, two,
three, "ptain." Right?
I mean, but the pause is
happening, and it's incredibly
informative, as I'll show you.
So that's the incredible
thing.
Your auditory system, your
language system, has to
reconstruct sound into
phonemes, into words.
It's not obvious in the physical
signal of the ear.
It's not even that the physical
signal at the ear
gives you much information at
the outset about whether
you're hearing one word or
two words or three words.
So here's "what," and "do you
mean" as one big blend.
Where is "do"?
Where is "you"?
Where is "you mean"?
And why does "what" look so
separate, and these three
words, "what do you mean,"
get all garbled together.
And you have to unpack them
by your brain and mind.
Here's another example.
John said that the dog
snapped at them.
The dog snapped.
Here's what's coming, roughly,
to your ear,
taken from spoken speech.
And here, again, notice that
the boundaries that you can
see here, the gaps of silence,
occur not very related to the
boundaries between the words
that your mind ultimately
understands.
So here's the word
"the," "dog".
Here's S for "snapped".
Here's a good pause.
But that's a pause between the
P sound and the T sound.
That looks like a good
word boundary.
To a machine, that's a very
good word boundary.
It's not a word boundary
for you.
You know snapped is one word.
And here comes "at." "At" is
kind of blended into the T. So
there's this physical signal
doesn't even give you breaks
where words separate
from one another.
It's kind of a continuous mix
of breaks and silences.
So here's to convince you that
a silence carries incredible
information in it.
Let's see, make sure
I have the volume.
OK, so I'm going to
play you this.
This is a physical signal to
your ear of the word "say."
RECORDING: Say.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yeah?
I always worry because Tyler's
an expert in this, and I'm
always like, please,
Tyler, don't
embarrass me when I'm wrong.
You don't have this pressure
out there, but the teaching
assistants are all experts
in something or another.
And then they know more often
than I do on that topic, and
we hit their topic
in the course.
I'm looking over there
nervously.
So here's "say." Now, they're
going to take this thing and
just separate this, just in
the way you do a physical
signal on a computer, just
separate in time.
They're just going to add
a little bit of time.
And what do you hear?
RECORDING: Stay.
PROFESSOR: The T sound that
makes is simply adding silence
here to produce that.
Now, that's what you
hear all the time.
It's not a random choice.
But isn't that amazing?
That silence is as ultimately
informative for your mind as
actual language sounds
themselves.
All this is happening on the
order of thousandths of a
second, in bits of
information.
That's bad enough.
Here's another amazingly
tough thing.
So people like to compare
consonants that have a lot of
similarities with some
interesting differences.
Ba and da.
This is really comparing B
versus D. It's throwing on the
A just to have a vowel sound.
So here, again, is a
representation of what's
coming to your ear.
Notice that all the difference
between the B and the D, these
two consonants, all the physical
differences occurring
in 40,000ths of a second.
40,000ths of a second is all the
physical difference that
you get as you hear
these two things.
RECORDING: Ba.
Da.
PROFESSOR: 40,000ths of a
second, and yet you could hear
the word bad, and you're
not going bad, dab.
Come on, that was thousandths
of a second, right?
And not only that, there'd be
another word and another word
in a sentence.
That's why people use the word
speech stream, and we like to
think of it as a
speech torrent.
Phonemes, phonemes, phonemes,
breaks, all garbled together
in your mind as you back and
constantly, instantly, and
brilliantly figure out
what you've heard.
So let me give you another
example because part of the
challenge of this are phonemes
occur in the context of words
and sentences.
So make sure I have good
volume on this.
OK, so let's do this
first one.
RECORDING: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What was that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Here's the same thing, and a
person is going to say this
now all by itself.
RECORDING: Little.
PROFESSOR: You got
that, right?
OK.
RECORDING: Mary saw the three
little pigs in the corridor.
PROFESSOR: OK, but here's
the amazing thing.
The first sound you heard, and
I'll replay it, they took the
word little, and they cut
it out from the last
sentence you heard.
When little is said all by
itself, what comes to your ear
is literally the first
thing you heard.
Not this, because when you say
a word in isolation, little,
people say it differently.
But we almost never
talk like that.
We almost always have
a sentence.
And it turns out the way we say
things, and therefore, the
way you hear things, is hugely
influenced by what comes
before it and what
comes after it.
Never mind things like the
speed at which different
people talk, the accent they
talk, or the loudness of the
background conversation.
But just simply the fact
that you're going to
say little by itself.
How does that work?
It's amazing, right?
Listen again.
If you heard little all by
itself, and it's exactly the
same physical signal.
Maybe it's not so--
RECORDING: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK?
Let me try that again.
RECORDING: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's exactly the
same physical signal, exactly
the same physical signal, as--
RECORDING: Mary saw the three
little pigs in the corridor.
PROFESSOR: What you
hear easily as
little is exactly that.
Words in isolation--
and there's a great
demonstration.
If you hear a word cut out, the
reason why it sounds like
nothing is your mind is already
preparing how to
interpret that, given what you
heard just before it, and also
a little bit what you
hear just after it.
Your mind is constantly fixing
up things because it knows
what's going on, what's going
into it, what's coming out.
It's not because it just simply
hears the word itself.
If we lived in a world where
people just say one word every
half an hour, we
could do this.
In a world where we're talking
to each other in sentences all
the time, we have to do this.
Here's another example of our
brilliant auditory system for
hearing these kinds of things.
So again, these are
representations of how this
physical signal arrives
at your ear.
Here's the word bet, bee,
boat, and bird.
They all start with
the same B sound.
That's easy, right?
But look what came
to your ear.
Look at this signal, this
signal, this signal.
Look at this one.
How different does this look?
It's different because what
follows bird influences how
this is said, but you can see
that you can translate both of
these into the B sound
pretty easily.
Now, look at these words.
These all start with D. Look
at how bet and debt look
almost identical.
We said it's only 40
milliseconds difference,
40,000ths of a second difference
that physically
moved through your ear.
But you can tell the word
bet versus debt.
Look at the word D, how
different it looks
from word to word.
So your mind is constantly
figuring
out what you're hearing.
The problem of invariance, and
it's constantly coming to you
in incredibly variable ways.
So one of the tools we have, and
an amazing human capacity,
is what's called categorical
perception.
So we have all this huge range
of physical sounds that can
come to our ear.
And kind of brilliantly,
and you don't
even think about it--
I mean, none of you go around
bragging about your
categorical perception
abilities, right?
Like when you go to spring
break, right?
And maybe some of you will go
home, or you'll see friends,
and you won't go, I have
categorical perception.
I try to be modest about it.
But it's an amazing human
talent, and essential because
what it does is this.
We hear this huge range of
sounds, depending on accents,
what comes before,
what comes after.
And we have to decide that's a
B. And what you're going to do
is take this huge range of
things, and just go, boom.
It's a B or a D, and that's
all there is to it.
So here's the way they do it.
So categorical perception.
Sounds can vary continuously.
We showed you some of
this continuity.
In this experiment, on purpose,
they're going to vary
sounds in a very continuous,
physical way.
But in our heads, for ba and da
here, in our heads, all the
stuff that's over here, even
though they're very different
one from the other at a
physical, specific level,
we'll say, ba.
I'm done with it.
We're going to put it in one
category for interpretation.
And you're going to have a
pretty sharp boundary here.
And then everything over here,
all these physical signals,
you're going to call pa.
And so you're not going to spend
a lot of time going,
that was a one third ba,
2/3 pa, probability.
You couldn't do that, right?
Because you couldn't
get through a
word, nevermind a sentence.
You're going to instantly group
huge numbers of things
that are different from one
another into two categories
that need to be separated.
So here's a kind of experiment
they do.
I'll just give you the
feeling of it.
Here's what they're varying,
constant units.
Constant units, every stimulus
here is different.
But every time you hear ba, and
they're constantly going
to vary something by its
physical property, you always
call it a B. And then something
happens, in about 20
milliseconds of information, and
boom, you always call it a
P. So change, change, change,
change, change, in the
physical signal, you call
it one category.
A little bit more
change, boom.
It's the other category.
And you keep changing, but for
you, it's always a perfectly
good P, even though every one
of those are different.
So it's an amazing fundamental
capacity to take a huge, and,
for all practical purposes, an
infinite variety of inputs and
say it's a B or a P if that's
the world I'm working in.
Syntax.
That's another way in which we
understand things, the way
that words are organized
and the order.
So we could say, "The model
embraced the designer and the
photographer." Imagine somebody
saying to this.
But then they complete the
sentence, "The model embraced
the designer and the
photographer laughed."
So people who study syntax
really are interested in what
happens in your mind as you
hear, "The model embraced the
designer and the photographer,"
and some big
group hug is going on, right?
And then all of a sudden, you
get this word laughed, and you
have to rearrange the elements
in your mind.
That's what syntax is letting
you do, to say, oh, the
meaning is really
quite different.
There's only one hug going on,
and one person laughing at
them, right?
But the meaning over time as
somebody talks to you set up,
you're thinking this, boom.
Because you understand syntax,
you understand what happens.
Semantics are kind of more
straightforward than how we
usually think about them.
They're the meaning of words
or sentences, morphemes.
And we can understand semantics
even when the
sentence is nonsense. "Colorless
green ideas sleep
furiously" is a famous
example.
We can understand semantics
even in bad grammatical
sentences, right?
"Fastly eat dinner, ballgame
start soon." Your fifth grade
teacher would be up in arms to
hear that, but you understand.
Eat now.
Go see the ball game.
So we get through a lot of
stuff to get semantics.
And we can see interactions.
I stole this example from Ted
Gibson because it took me 20
minutes to figure out what
the sentence means.
You're probably faster
than I am.
Are you OK?
I'm like the old man.
Where's the missing words?
The old man the boats.
So this is how you have to
parse up the sentence.
It's not always obvious.
People who study language love
these things, where people are
all confused.
Most of our lives, we don't go
through that much confusion.
But there's some fun ones,
sort of like the visual
illusions, to point out how
meaning and syntax can
interact as you figure
out things.
Here's another example.
Jay Leno talked about sex
with Lindsey Lohan.
OK, now wait a minute.
Did I miss that excellent
episode of Jay Leno, or was
she on the show, and talking
about-- she was saying I'd
rather not talk about my
recent conviction.
I'd rather talk about something
less controversial.
So semantic.
All these things are constantly
interacting in your mind.
It's kind of amazing when you
think about that, right?
We said phonology's amazing.
Semantics, syntax, boom.
They're all happening in you.
And none of you are
sitting there,
going, just do phonology.
Please don't ask me
to do semantics.
We just had midterms, right?
Brilliant.
So one of the ways that people
try to convince themselves
that these things are separable
and gives a little
bit more insight is Evoked
Response Potentials.
Those are these things that you
can measure on infants or
adults that measure electrical
activity in milliseconds and
the speed of language
processing, surface electrodes
that give you an index of a few
hundred thousand neurons.
And this is an example you saw
before, actually, earlier in
the course, the so-called
N400.
So N means whether the
wave is going up or
down, negative or positive.
400 means that it occurs about
400 milliseconds, about half a
second, after the
relevant event.
So here is this, let's see, it
was his first day at work.
That's the baseline.
He spread the warm
bread with socks.
Oh my gosh, socks.
Semantically bad.
And here comes the N400.
And the control condition is you
throw up this unexpected
word, shoes, that's weird, but
not semantically, and you get
quite a different response.
So here's an N400 that seems
to simply be about semantic
expectation or congruence.
How about if you
mess up syntax?
The spoiled child throw
the toys on the box.
Then you get a response at
about 600 milliseconds to
syntactic incongruity.
So people, this is just more
evidence that in the brain,
meaning or semantics and syntax
or something about word
order are processed somewhat
differently in time and place.
Pragmatics is kind of fun.
It's practical understanding.
The old joke, do you know
what time it is?
And the person says, yes.
They're messing with your
sense of pragmatics.
Two negatives make a positive.
Saying, yeah, yeah.
I've heard that one before,
earlier in the lecture.
Now, here's something kind of
interesting, again, which is
remarkable.
And if you didn't do the
experiment, you couldn't know
that our mind is like this.
Because you wouldn't do things
like this because it sounds
too ridiculous, but your mind
does it all the time.
So we're going to think about
the word "bugs." And I have to
set you up a little bit with
paradigms you've heard before,
but just remind you
of these things.
So one kind of task that
psychologists like to use to
think about how people
process words is a
lexical decision task.
All you're deciding is whether
a word is a real word or a
nonsense word.
So doctor is real.
Poctor is not.
Spy is a real word.
This spelling is not
a real word.
So real word, not a real word.
We also talked about one other
idea early in the course, that
if, prior to processing a word
like doctor, you get an
unrelated word or a related
word, you process doctor
faster if you had a related
word before it.
Semantic priming.
The ideas about nurse
overlap a lot with
the ideas about doctor.
And seeing this word
before makes you
process this word faster.
So you need those two
things in mind.
What was the person doing?
Is it a real word or not?
And you're going to mess with
what's in their mind before
that, related or unrelated.
And here's the experiment.
So you would hear, over
headphones, something like
this, as an example.
"Rumor has it that for years
the government building had
been plagued with
problems." Now,
here's a critical sentence.
"The man was not surprised when
he found several spiders,
roaches, and other bugs in
the corner of his room."
So there's two senses of the
word, at least two meanings of
the word bug, right?
The insect you don't want in
your soup, or the microphone
that somebody slipped into
your room to listen to
what's going on.
Two different meanings
for the word bug.
This is obviously about
the insect.
So the person is hearing this
over headphones, and on a
computer monitor in front of
them, after they hear the word
bugs here, they see, for a
lexical decision, the word
"ant," which is related to this
meaning, or "spy," which
is related to the other meaning
that's not relevant
for here, or "sew," which is
the control condition.
We'll ignore that because it's
just a control condition.
I'll ignore that for now.
So you're making a lexical
decision now on the related
meaning or the unrelated
meaning.
And here's what they find.
If it's the related meaning, and
you only have about a half
second from when that came on
to when you had to do this
task, so you saw the word
bug and here comes
this, you're faster.
But if you get the unrelated
meaning within a half a second
of processing the word,
you're also faster.
What this means is, your mind
has done exactly what you
would think it wouldn't do.
Your mind has looked up in
your brain, and in your
knowledge of vocabulary, every
meaning of the word.
Even though the sentence is
clearly setting you up for the
word, the insect meaning, every
meaning of your word is
turned on and available
to you.
Your mind does the opposite
of what you might think.
You might think, well, I know--
let's look at the sentence.
I know, once I get spiders,
roaches, and bugs.
By here, you know you're in the
insect world, not in the
world of spies, right?
But your mind, even then, looks
up every possible word.
Because it's cheaper for the
mind to look up every word
than to start to decide what
the appropriate word is.
And then, if you wait another
second and a half, you're only
fast for the selected meaning.
And now you're slowed
down for the one
that's not context relevant.
So your mind looks up everything
all the time.
Every meaning of every
word you know.
Every time that word pops up, it
seems like your mind looks
up every meaning, and then the
rest of your mind selects out
the one that's relevant
and shuts down the
ones that are not.
But you wouldn't think that.
You would think, maybe I'll
just get the one I need.
I'm not going to
get everything.
It's like, I'm not going to put
all my clothes on, walk
outside, and take off everything
that's not relevant
for the weather, right?
It seems like a really
inefficient way to get
dressed, right?
But that's not the
way your mind is.
Your mind is cheaper and more
efficient to look up every
meaning every time, and then
pick the right one.
It's more efficient, and that's
how people do it.
So people use this word
exhaustive lexical access.
I look up every meaning of a
word, and then I'll pick out
the correct one.
Another interesting aspect that
could be brought into
pragmatics, and we'll talk a
little bit more about this
later in the course, but
emotional intonation.
And it turns out where it's
almost all language processes
are left dominance as
we talked about many
times in the course.
One stream of processing
language, both visual and
auditory, is right hemisphere
dependent.
And that's emotional
intonation.
And that brings us to
our reading for
today, from Oliver Sacks.
And I have to say, I think
Oliver Sacks is a phenomenal
author, but there's always been
this sense of some of
these stories are just a bit
too true to be-- just a bit
cute, or whatever it is.
And so for years, I taught
from this story, and I
believed it's likely true.
But I thought, well, it's
just a little cute.
And then came an experiment
that showed it's not only
cute, but it's exactly
correct.
So for this, you appreciate this
a bit more if you know a
couple things about Ronald
Reagan, who was
president in the 1980s.
So what do you guys know
about Ronald Reagan?
What party?
AUDIENCE: Republican.
PROFESSOR: There you go.
Was he considered a
good communicator?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
He was considered-- you know,
you can have all kinds of
views on Ronald Reagan's
things.
The public said, he's an
awesome communicator.
In fact, Barack Obama said he
would like to communicate like
Ronald Reagan.
Whether that's to get Republican
votes or not,
that's your judgment.
But he was considered an
excellent communicator.
Was he considered, by and large,
to be an extremely
analytic thinker?
He might have been.
I don't know him.
But not so much.
Now, part of this is the
prejudice or not, but he was
from California, and he was
an actor before he became
president, or the governor
president.
He also had some degree of--
well, he ultimately got
Alzheimer's disease.
It's a question about later in
his administration, whether he
was already working his
way towards that.
So anyway, complicated things.
So he was a master communicator,
but not
necessarily the Barack Obama,
Bill Clinton, Jimmy Carter
version of an analytic power,
is the general perception.
You never know whether
these are right or
wrong for the person.
But in the story, listening to
the president's speech, are
patients with aphasia that
Oliver Sacks described, and
he's getting laughter as they're
watching his speech.
And what happens is, some of
the people with a left
hemisphere lesion-- so you
have a language problem.
We'll see a video of that
pretty shortly.
They're laughing because they
think that the way he's
talking and his facial
expressions, they find hilarious.
Now, why do they find
it hilarious?
They have damage to the parts
of the brain that help them
understand the content of
his message on the left
hemisphere.
And here's what Sacks
thinks is going on.
"The feelings I have, which
all of us who work closely
with aphasics have, is that you
cannot lie to an aphasic.
He cannot grasp your words, and
so be deceived by them.
But what he grasps, he grasps
with infallible precision,
namely, the expression that
goes with the words, that
total spontaneous, involuntary
expressiveness which can never
be simulated or faked, or
words alone can hide all
sometimes too easily."
So when you give a very public
speech, especially under tough
circumstances, that presidents
sometimes have to do, we
sometimes think there's a
tension between exactly what
they're saying and exactly
what they're thinking.
And what they feel they need to
say, and exactly what they
know is behind the scenes.
And so the idea is that these
aphasics, they were saying
this guy obviously doesn't
mean what he's saying.
Look at his face.
Look at his tone.
I don't know what he's saying,
but it's hilarious, how he's
masking his face and speaking
in a funny tone to tell
something he truly
doesn't believe.
That's their interpretation.
And yet, he has an opposite
patient, a patient with a
right hemisphere lesion.
We said that's the side of
the hemisphere that seems
important for facial expressions
and emotional
intonation.
And she complains about the
logic of the case he's making,
as if having--
normally, when we talk to
somebody, it's both.
Left hemisphere's getting
the content,
analyzing the content.
Right hemisphere, something
about the intonation.
True or not true?
Are their eyes like this, and
they can't even face us as
they tell us something
they know is false.
But these patients, maybe
because they have one channel
of information knocked out
because of injury, they become
hypersensitive to
the other one.
So I thought, well, that
sounds fantastically
interesting, but is
that really true?
So here in Boston, they did a
study with a large number of
patients that says they had
superior identification of
people who are lying to you--
they had made video clips and
audio clips of people who are
lying to you--
if they had a left hemisphere
lesion.
So this is a paper.
So here's the two examples.
So they have an example.
Let's pick this one.
Where both, you see
just a facial
expression of a person talking.
The voice is turned down.
Your job is to decide whether
a person is lying or not.
And some videos they're lying.
Some videos they're not.
So how would you do?
I don't know how you would do,
but I can tell you how a group
of Harvard undergraduates did.
50% is chance, and here's
how they did.
That was one of their
control groups.
And, in fact, for studies like
this, they brought in many,
many kinds of people to ask
whether anybody is better.
Everybody's pretty much terrible
at directly telling
whether a lie is going on.
Now, these are video clips of
people you don't know in
circumstances you don't know.
That could matter.
But everybody's terrible
at that.
Policemen are terrible.
FBI agents are terrible.
The only group that seems to be
above chance, and not much
above it, are Secret
Service agents.
So if you're friend with a
Secret Service agent, and you
want to deceive them, keep in
mind that they seem to be
above chance.
They're not awesome, but
they're above chance.
But look who's doing better than
everybody, patients with
the left hemisphere lesions.
And the interpretation
is, all the content
of the lie is gone.
All they see is your expression,
or your expression
and intonation.
And because that's all they have
to go on, they can tell
more when you have the
discomfort of lying than a
person who's partly persuaded by
hearing the message you're
sending as you talk.
So I thought this was an overly
cute example, but it
turns out to be exactly
replicable in a full study.
Any questions about that?
OK.
So let's talk a little
bit about the
brain basis of language.
We've talked a little
bit about--
we know that if you have damage
here, you have Broca's
aphasia on the left hemisphere,
trouble producing language.
Damage here, Wernicke's
aphasia, trouble
comprehending language.
To a first approximation, and
there's a lot of research that
has made this much more
complicated, but a first
approximation, the lesions
are in frontal
cortex or temporal cortex.
The speech in these patients are
what's called non-fluent
or telegraphic.
They get single words out but
have a hard time with anything
like a sentence.
It can be very frustrating
for these patients.
Wernicke's patients
seem much happier.
You'll see a film in a moment.
Their speech is fluent,
but it's
amazingly empty of content.
These patients have trouble
producing speech, but their
comprehension is decent.
These patients produce speech
pretty well, but their
comprehension.
So they're mirror opposites.
And let's see, what do I want?
Yes.
So in this field, a frequently,
incredibly
frequently used picture
to study aphasia is
this specific picture.
It's called the cookie
theft picture.
Why it's become widely used,
I'm not exactly sure.
But once it's widely used, then
often everybody uses it.
So they'll put a picture like
this in front of an
individual, and they'll
ask them to describe
what's going on.
It's to elicit production.
And you would say something
like, there's two kids.
The kid's on a stool.
Uh oh, is he going
to fall over?
Because they're falling off
the cookie jar, and the
mother's sort of not
paying attention.
Her mind must be somewhere else
because she's letting the
water splish splash
here, right?
You would say something
like that.
So let's see what patients with
aphasia say, and other
examples of their difficulty
with language.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Their writing tends
to go pretty much with their
spoken language.
That's a really good question
about-- so the question is,
what would their writing
be like?
It very much parallels their
spoken language.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
sign language?
PROFESSOR: OK, so very
good question.
Could not fluent aphasics learn
sign language to bypass,
in a sense, their
problem, right?
So I'm about to answer
that in a moment,
right on the next slide.
Not directly that, but the
implication of that.
Because the important thing is--
so let me show you this
thing, and let me come back.
The question is, could you train
an aphasic to use sign
language to get around his or
her language problem, if it's
a speech problem?
So people have studied sign
language as a language for
many reasons, but a
huge one is this.
Because I'm going to interpret
your question the way I need
to, and then you can tell me
if I did it right from your
perspective.
Which is, in what sense does
language equal speech?
Could you communicate
linguistically like, but just
switch to your hands, if for
some reason-- and the answer
is, that at the level of the
problem of these patients,
they could not do it.
Because these kinds of patients,
the problem isn't
really speech.
There are people who have
problems with the motor
apparatus to move their mouth.
That does exist.
Their problem is in language
processes that produce your
speech intent, or language
processes that extract meaning
from sounds.
And those language processes
that produce what you want to
say, that comprehend what you
hear or read, those are the
same ones that are utilized,
as far as we understand,
whether you're producing
language in the typical, vocal
way, or in the less
typical, but
well-studied, way of sign language.
Does that make sense?
OK.
So you can't get around
it because
it's a language problem.
So both by brain imaging
evidence, for example, here
are patients who use sign
language turning on Broca's
area and Wernicke's area
on tasks that are about
comprehension and production.
It's the same areas, whether
it's using your hands for sign
language or using your mouth to
talk or your ear to hear.
Further, there have been really
fun studies where they
took deaf infants and have
shown-- and it's not easy to
show, but I think most people
are convinced that they babble
with their hands.
The same way babies make
little sounds to get
themselves going.
We'll talk more about
infants in a moment.
Infants who grow up in an
environment where they only
learn sign language babble
with their hands because
speech, language is not about
your mouth talking.
It's about ideas that you can
communicate by your production
or comprehension, by your
hand or by your mouth.
So language is separable from
speech, because even without
speech, you communicate in very
much the same way, in
terms of sign language,
by many studies.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So does that mean that
people that [INAUDIBLE]
imagined words or language?
PROFESSOR: Say that
again, sorry?
AUDIENCE: Does that mean that
they also couldn't imagine
words or language?
PROFESSOR: Who couldn't?
AUDIENCE: People with Broca's
area aphasia.
PROFESSOR: I don't think so.
We talked about this
before, that--
I may not be understanding your
question exactly, but--
in many ways, imagining
something is the same part of
the brain that does it.
When we imagine a face, we
turn on the parts of
our brain that sees.
I think when you imagine,
if you--
I do this sometimes.
I say, here's what I'm
going to say to that
person, in my head.
And I practice that
little speech.
That's this part of the brain
pretty much running.
There's just a last little step
of moving your mouth, but
from the discussion we're having
now, that's kind of a
superficial thing of
moving your mouth.
That's not speech planning,
speech thinking, speech
intentions.
Those are our core process for
production, for comprehension,
and I think imagined stuff
is exactly the same way.
Is that OK?
Yeah.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So if they can't
really imagine language, then
how do they-- what is
their thinking like?
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's a good--
so the question is, if
they have these troubles with
core language ideas,
abilities, what's their
thinking like?
I could just tell you, it's a
classic debate for humans, how
deeply language equals
thought.
But language [INAUDIBLE]
in a sense of speech.
It's just one of those things
that people debate a lot
because it depends what you mean
by these things in many
different ways.
But if language means something
like comprehending
ideas in the world, it's hard
to get around that for
thinking [INAUDIBLE].
It means planning actions in
the world that change the
world around you, and
communicating that, it's hard
to not have that capacity for
thinking in that way, right?
So it's at this level, not
whether you use your hands or
your mouth, it's very hard to
separate out what you might
call thought and what you
might call language.
But keep in mind that these
patients that we see, it's not
like they lost all of
language at all.
So even the Broca's aphasic
has trouble producing
language, he's producing
some, and he
comprehends it pretty well.
So it's not like these patients
have lost all of
their language circuitry, and
therefore don't have thought
available, right?
They have a lot of language left
in their head, and a lot
of thought left in their mind.
Is that OK?
So one interesting thing that
people have wondered, and
where brain imaging gives us
evidence that we couldn't have
imagined 15 years
ago, is this.
So if you have damage, let's
say, here's a patient with
damage to the left
frontal area.
And they get better because
they've had a stroke here or
an injury here.
They get better.
A question that people have
wondered is, do they get
better by sort of somehow
recovering ability in a part
of their brain that
got injured?
Or do they get better because
they use an entirely different
pathway in their brain?
Now, until brain imaging,
you couldn't begin
to touch that question.
But now we have some evidence,
and I'll make it just--
and so here's an example of a
patient who has damage here.
They have him do a task that
in healthy people turns on
exactly that place.
And when he does it,
he can do it OK.
And where does he do it?
In his right hemisphere.
So this patient seems to switch
which hemisphere he
uses for language.
It takes time and training
to recover that.
But it seems like he's found
an alternate pathway to
produce a language somehow.
Turns out that the more people
have studied these things, the
more complicated it gets.
Maybe just diversity of people,
diversity of injuries,
or whatever.
So it doesn't always
work this way.
But often, it seems like when
people have better recovery
from a large injury to the
speaking left hemisphere, they
find a way, somehow, through
practice and training, to get
the right hemisphere to take
over some of those
responsibilities.
Language acquisition.
So one of the most amazing
things about infants is they
go from zero to speech in just
a couple of years, and go
through an unbelievable training
and program of
development.
So what happens?
In two or three months, they
perceive all the phonemes.
They notice this change
in phonemes.
By six months, they start to
ignore distinctions among
sounds that are not used
in their language.
In other words, other
language sounds.
They start to babble, in
some way getting their
speech ready to go.
By eight months, they start to
identify single words in a
speech stream.
In a year, their babbling
becomes
more adult-like sounding.
But a little bit after that,
they get up to about 50 words
in understanding.
So comprehension always goes
ahead of production.
Children understand words before
they can speak them.
But they're lagging.
Here comes a speech, telegraphic
speech, short
sentences at two years.
And then, finally, pretty
complete speech, in
many ways, by nine.
So it's a long, long process,
learning 10,000 words
estimated by the age of six.
That's a spectacular
learning curve.
When they do experiments on
infants where they measure
things like preference or
learning by sucking rates on a
nipple because they can't talk,
they try to figure out,
what is the infant hearing.
Within two hours of birth, they
suck with more enthusiasm
to their mother's voice
over another voice.
These are infants, this
is their first
visit to their mother.
You have to sign up to
do this experiment.
Now, they might have heard
their mother's voice in a
certain way in the
womb, right?
But they already have picked
up, by three-day-old, they
prefer language to many other
sounds, like music.
We come to love music, but
that's not the urgent business
of the infant.
By four days old, they start
to notice the differences
between languages.
This is amazing.
Their rate of learning
is fantastic.
And by two months, they can tell
the ba-ga distinction,
subtle distinctions, 40
milliseconds information.
And then they develop a
continuingly strong preference
for the sounds of their
native language.
Now, some years ago, people
debated endlessly this left
hemisphere specialization
for language.
This is fantastically essential
and striking in humans.
Does that grow over time,
or is it in your mind
and brain at birth?
And the evidence is pretty
compelling for many sources,
but here is maybe the most.
Here's fMRI on two-day-old
infants.
You might ask, how do they
instruct the infants to lie
still in the scanner and
participate in the experiment?
And the answer is, at two days
old, infants mostly just lay
there and don't do much.
They don't do much.
And there's a lot going on in
their mind, but they don't
have much physical apparatus
to do much.
So you could swaddle them very
warmly, and just lay--
you put them on a cradle
into the fMRI scanner.
Their parents have signed
up for them.
And you could play them sounds
while they just lay there and
do nothing.
They can't push buttons.
They can't do stuff.
But you can see what's happening
inside their brain.
And at two days old, here's the
left hemisphere response
to language compared
to the right.
So it's there instantly,
we believe.
It's been there, actually in the
womb as the child's been
developing.
This left hemisphere,
genetically set up dominance
for language in almost
everybody.
fMRI, just for those
of you who--
again, we can start doing it
at about age five, but from
about three months to age five,
it's incredibly hard to
do children in a scanner.
But the first couple days,
it's not so hard.
Now, a really interesting
line of research has
talked about motherese.
Have you heard this term?
So how do grown-ups,
even college
students, talk to babies?
Do you talk to babies
just like you talk
to everybody else?
No.
Cute baby.
Baby, baby.
And everybody looks like
an idiot, right?
And you could just think, OK,
that's just people being
idiots around babies.
But it turns out there's been
beautiful, beautiful studies
to show that, while you
spontaneously do this-- and
you and I don't take motherese
or fatherese courses--
but what we do spontaneously
is that way of elongating
sounds, the intonations we give,
are incredibly perfect
to help the baby
learn language.
We're exactly doing what
they can understand.
And that, again, must
be virtually in
our genes, I think.
We hear it around,
so it's not zero.
But the short pauses, careful
enunciation, exaggerated
intonation, that's--
you could do experiments where
you take language and you get
rid of those, and the babies
are like-- they don't know
what's going on.
They're not interested.
You put them back in, boom.
Those are perfect
for the baby.
It's amazing, not only how
babies are ready to go, but
how adults who talk with
them are ready to go.
I mean, it's just amazing.
None of us will ever be as good
a teacher in a classroom
as all of you will be
with a baby anytime
you talk with them.
It's just amazing.
So there's beautiful experiments
that show that
every time you tinker with the
way the mother spontaneously,
or parents spontaneously, talk
to indants, you make it worse,
less interesting, and less
informative for the infant.
So now let's talk about a
more formal experiment.
These are the classic experiment
that nailed home
this message, that at birth
we're universal understanders
of all sounds in the world.
And as the years go along, we
became only good at the sounds
that are relevant, that are
part of our own language.
A famous example in the US is
a difficulty for Japanese
native speakers for the
R-L distinction.
But every language has some
distinctions it doesn't make,
and they're really hard
when you get older.
So here's the idea.
In English, we make a
distinction between ba and da,
and by 10 to 12 months, an
infant can make that
distinction.
And certainly, adults can.
That's categorical perception
that we talked about, that
kind of division between
ba and da.
But there's sounds that occur
in other language.
So we're shown here.
And you're going to hear--
some of you may know Hindi
sounds, and it'll be a
different experience for you.
Every year, when I first hear
this clip I'm about to show
you, I think something's
wrong.
Because they say, the infant's
going to tell the difference
between da and da.
And I go, well, how are
they going to do that?
I can't do that.
That's because they really are
different sounds you're
hearing, but in English, they're
not different sounds.
And so it all sounds
the same to me.
I'm no longer a universal
learner.
I haven't been since
quite a while.
So here we go.
I'm stunned, always, by the
brilliance of infant
researchers like this, who
somehow, pretty convincingly
in most cases, really tell you
what the infant knows or pays
attention to or thinks in pretty
compelling ways, even
though they can't tell
you themselves.
So one thing that's come
up in the US--
I mean, the whole world is
becoming ever more bilingual
and trilingual.
There used to be some concerns,
less now, and I'll
tell you, you don't have
to worry about it.
Whether it's bad to learn
two languages at once
when you're a kid.
And some parents worry
about this, right?
You're going to be all messed
up because you're going to
blend them all up and not
do well in school.
And so there's been quite a
bit of research, actually,
tracking and asking whether
there's any downside.
I mean, there's huge
upsides to knowing
two or three languages.
Are there any downsides in terms
of language development?
And the objective evidence is
pretty compelling that for
babbling, for first words, for
pairs of words at a time,
[INAUDIBLE] at two months, that
there's really no cost.
So they followed, in Canada, for
example, children who grew
up learning English and French,
English and ASL,
French or English only.
Everybody does the same,
pretty much.
There's no cost, compared
to the huge gain.
Sometimes some kids will
get a little mixed up.
They'll actually mix up
languages because they'll just
mix them up when they're
pretty young.
But there's no developmental
delay of milestones or
negative consequences.
There's only the benefit of
having two or three languages
that you could speak.
So the evidence is overwhelming,
empirically,
that there's no cost for
learning more than one
language at a time when
you're an infant.
One thing, there is a cost, a
little bit, if you're a boy.
So unknown why this happened.
I don't think there's any
deep science about it.
But everybody has observed that,
for example, number of
new words understood during the
first two years of life,
that girls, on average,
outperform boys in language
acquisition early on.
And then things get closer,
pretty much.
But the rate of learning
on girls on average
is faster than boys.
Nobody, I think, understands
the specific basis of that.
So when people talk about
critical periods in language
acquisition, and what are
fragile or resilient aspects
of language.
Which aspects of learning
language that seem very
dependent on the age you are,
and which are independent.
So phonology, including the
production of language sounds,
seems very fragile.
Easy when you're young, harder
when you're older.
Grammar is also age-sensitive,
making subtle grammatical
distinctions.
Learning about meaning or
vocabulary, you're perfectly
fine when you're an adult.
That doesn't seem to
show something
like a sensitive period.
And here's one famous study
that established
some of these things.
They looked at what age people
arrive to different countries,
from different countries
to the US and
started learning English.
These are people that didn't
know English before.
They're all adults now, and
they had them do quickly
grammatical judgments.
And what they found is, if you
came to the US when you--
if you were born in the US, or
you came to the age three to
seven, you were very
good at doing this.
But the later you came here, 8
to 10 years of age, 11 to 15,
17 to 39, your ability to make
these fast, subtle grammatical
judgments just went down.
Even though you've been here, in
many cases, for many years.
You're very smart.
Accents are like that, right?
People come to the US at a
certain point in their
development.
They're very skilled in
English, have a big
vocabulary, but the accent
never disappears.
That's another thing in terms
of language production that
has its fragile developmental
early period.
So the last thing I'll do, and
then show you a movie for
about eight minutes.
We get this occasional
horrible experiments.
It's not even an experiment
of nature.
It's just an experiment of
horrible human behavior.
And the most famous one in
language development, which
had a huge impact on
the field at the
time, is a child, Genie.
I'll show you.
You'll see her in a movie
clip in a moment.
They discovered her locked in
a room, in a house, from age
20 months, approximately,
until they
discovered her at 13.
She almost spoke to no one.
So the people taking care of
her locked her in a closet,
basically, and did not talk
with her, or she had no
language interactions
until she was
discovered and rescued.
And then they performed research
for years saying
could she learn things, what
could she not learn.
She got single words, for
example, but she never got
particularly good at grammar.
[INAUDIBLE]
syntax.
So a brutal way to test the idea
that what's acquirable
later in life.
And what, if you don't learn
it early in life, is
impossible to acquire fully?
So I'll end with this.
We'll do this for five minutes
or seven minutes.
I'll stop there.
It's summarized in your book.
Everybody knows about it because
it's this study you
couldn't do ethically
in a million years.
You would never do, which is if
you deprive a child of the
critical period of language
exposure.
And she never got lots of
aspects of language going.
She got OK on a minimal
vocabulary,
grew in other ways.
But many of the things that,
from a language perspective,
she never got because she missed
that critical period.
So that's a bit of a sad story,
obviously, but have a
good spring break and a
refreshing spring break.
And I'll see you in 10 days.